A few months ago, all of us here at This American Life heard that there's this test that they give to determine if somebody is a psychopath. And we thought, we want to take that. So we asked a forensic psychologist, Dr. David Bernstein, who gives this test all the time, to administer the test to us. He took us each into a room, gave us about an hour of questions.
几个月前，我们《美国生活》节目的所有人都听说有这样一种测试，可以用来判断某人是否为精神变态者。我们想，我们也得测一下。于是，我们请了一位经常做这项测试的法医心理学家大卫·伯恩斯坦博士（Dr. David Bernstein）为我们进行评估。他把我们每一个人单独叫进房间，问了大约一个小时的问题。
As a child, did you get into a lot of fights?
你小时候经常打架吗？
I would say beat up more than got into-- [LAUGHTER]
我觉得与其说是打架，不如说被打得多—— [笑声]
When you were young, did you ever do rowdy things outside of school, like vandalize, break windows, set fires, hurt animals, or young children, anything like that? Steal?
你年轻的时候，在校外有没有做过粗鲁的事情？比如蓄意破坏、打破窗户、放火、伤害动物或幼童之类的？有没有偷窃过？
No. There was a video that we watched in school that really warned me against it. The one thing that I did do--
没有。我们在学校看过一个视频，真的给我留下了深刻的警示。我唯一做过的一件事——
And you graduated high school?
那你高中毕业了吗？
Yes.
毕业了。
And what did you do after leaving high school?
高中毕业后你做了什么？
I did an internship, actually, at National Public Radio, like all budding psychopaths.
其实，我像所有初出茅庐的精神变态一样，在全国公共广播电台（NPR）实习过。
Now, to be clear, Dr. Bernstein gave us the shorter version of the psychopath test, and he was not as rigorous as he would have been with real potential psychopaths. For instance, he didn't check police records to independently verify everything that each one of us said. Because, of course, we did not expect to find a psychopath on our staff. Though, to be honest, it wasn't until Dr. Bernstein actually arrived at our office and started administering these things that we really, I think, all fully understood just how far gone a true psychopath is. He explained to us a psychopath has no empathy at all, no sense of mercy, no conscience. They don't experience love.
需要说明的是，伯恩斯坦博士给我们做的是精神变态测试的简易版，他并不像对待真正的潜在精神变态者那样严格。例如，他没有去查警方的记录来独立核实我们每个人所说的一切。因为当然了，我们没指望在员工中发现精神变态者。说实话，直到伯恩斯坦博士真的来到办公室并开始进行测试时，我想我们才真正完全理解一个真正的精神变态者到底有多严重。他向我们解释说，精神变态者完全没有同理心，没有慈悲感，没有良心。他们无法体验爱。
They could tell you what these things mean, particularly the smarter ones, the brighter ones. They could even, the brighter ones, will learn to fake it. But they could not experience it.
他们能告诉你这些词的意思，特别是那些更聪明、更敏锐的人。那些聪明人甚至会学会伪装。但他们无法真正体验。
But you work with people all the time. Think of any group of people that you know well. Friends, relatives, your state's congressional delegation. And sometimes you see them and the thought crosses your mind, OK, this person isn't a psychopath, but there's tendencies. There's a little note of something. And, of the people on the staff who took the test-- that's Julie, Jonathan, me, Sarah, Jane, Ben, Robyn, and Nancy-- we all did have our suspicions.
但你一直在和人打交道。想想你熟悉的任何一群人。朋友、亲戚、你们州的国会代表团。有时你看着他们，脑海中会闪过一个念头：好吧，这个人不是精神变态，但他有一些倾向。有一丝异样的迹象。在参加测试的员工中——朱莉、乔纳森、我、莎拉、简、本、罗宾和南希——我们每个人确实都有所怀疑。
So why were you in there for two hours, Robyn?
那么罗宾，你为什么在里面待了两个小时？
Yeah, why were you in there for two hours?
对啊，你为什么在里面待了两个小时？
I don't know. There's a lot of questions. There's so many questions.
我不知道。问题很多。问题多得数不清。
He told me that you were actually a bit transgressive, more than others.
他告诉我，你其实比其他人稍微更有越轨行为。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes. He said that coming out.
是的。他说你表现得更显眼。
Who's you? Robyn?
你指谁？罗宾吗？
Robyn.
罗宾。
Robyn, yes. Robyn was more rebellious than those.
罗宾，是的。罗宾比其他人更叛逆。
Yeah, he did say that.
是啊，他的确那么说。
Wow, really?
哇，真的吗？
Yeah, he did say that, but--
是的，他确实那么说了，但是——
The test, if you want to know, asks about your family, whether you've been in love, your favorite and least favorite things about love, what kind of employee you are, plus these general questions that really make you think about what a psychopath is. Like, have you done crazy or dangerous things for fun? Do you think people are easy to con or manipulate? Do people tell you-- this one's sort of scary-- do people tell you that you have a bad temper?
如果你想知道的话，测试会问到你的家庭，你是否谈过恋爱，你对爱情最喜欢和最讨厌的地方，你是什么样的员工，以及这些让你深思何为精神变态的一般性问题。比如，你有没有为了找乐子而做过疯狂或危险的事情？你认为人们容易被欺骗或操纵吗？有没有人告诉你——这条有点可怕——有没有人说你脾气暴躁？
But a surprisingly large part of the questionnaires is about things that you did when you were a kid, when you were a teenager. So Robyn, with the stuff that she did in high school, seemed like she might score at least a couple points. And so did Jane. Jane had run-ins with the law as a teenager. Here's how she answered Dr. Bernstein when he asked, how would your teachers describe your behavior in high school?
问卷中很大一部分令人惊讶地是关于你小时候、青少年时期所做的事情。所以，以罗宾在高中时做过的事来看，她似乎至少能得几分。简也是。简在青少年时期曾与法律发生过冲突。当伯恩斯坦博士问她“你的老师会如何描述你在高中的表现”时，她是这样回答的。
Rebellious, irresponsible.
叛逆，不负责任。
Underachiever?
成绩低下？
Yeah. Because I could have done a lot better. I'm sure they thought that.
是啊。因为我本可以做得好得多。我敢肯定他们是这么想的。
What kind of grades did you get?
你得了什么样的分数？
A's, and then over time, D's. Yeah, to where I quit, basically, because I was failing all of my classes, and I didn't want to be there anyway.
一开始是A，后来逐渐变成了D。是的，基本上我退学了，因为我所有的课都不及格，而且我反正也不想待在那里。
So, when we were all sitting around talking after we took the test, still waiting to get our scores, talking about whether we had been nervous taking it, there was one more person besides Jane and Robyn that everybody thought might score at least a couple points on the psychopath scale.
所以，当我们测试结束后坐在一起聊天，等着拿分数时，还在讨论我们在测试时是否感到紧张，除了简和罗宾之外，每个人都认为还有一个人至少能拿几分。
Who do you guys think is going to have the highest score?
你们觉得谁的分数会最高？
You.
你。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yes.
没错。
Well, wait. So, Ira, wait. Were you nervous?
好吧，等等。艾拉，等等。你当时紧张吗？
I was very nervous. Yeah, I was.
我非常紧张。是的，我是。
Are you still, after taking it?
测试完之后你还紧张吗？
A little.
有一点。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I am nervous for you.
我为你感到紧张。
Me, too. I think I'm nervous.
我也是。我想我也很紧张。
Well, today on our radio show, what it is in me that the people I work with see as possibly psychopathic. And two of our favorite contributors, Alix Spiegel and the very funny Jon Ronson, each has been spending lots of time investigating the psychopath test, figuring out what it can tell us and what it cannot tell us. It's a test that's used in criminal justice systems all over the world. They explain why that may be worrisome. That, and of course, our scores. Who on our staff scored the highest on the psychopath test, me, Jane, Robyn, or some yet-to-be-named dark horse? Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的广播节目中，将探讨我身上有哪些特质被同事看作是潜在的精神变态。我们最喜欢的两位撰稿人，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和非常风趣的乔恩·罗森（Jon Ronson），一直在花大量时间调查精神变态测试，弄清楚它能告诉我们什么，又不能告诉我们什么。这是一项在世界各地的刑事司法系统中使用的测试。他们将解释为什么这可能令人担忧。当然，还有我们的分数。我们员工中谁在精神变态测试中得分最高？是我，简，罗宾，还是某位还没提到的黑马？请继续收听。
Act One, Underachievement Test.
第一幕，成绩低下测试。
The psychopath test that we're talking about all this hour is used by prisons, and by courtrooms. And the questions on the test are supposed to measure whether you have any of the traits on this checklist of 20 traits that scientists have observed in psychopaths. Lack of remorse, impulsivity, failure to take responsibility for your actions, pathological lying, sexual promiscuity. And because it's a checklist, sometimes people just call the test "the checklist," though sometimes they call it by its formal name, the PCL-R, which stands for Psychopathy Check List Revised.
我们这一整小时谈论的精神变态测试被监狱和法庭所使用。测试中的问题旨在衡量你是否具备科学家在精神变态者身上观察到的那20种特征清单中的任何一种。缺乏悔意、冲动、逃避个人行为责任、病态撒谎、性滥交。正因为这是一个检查清单，人们有时直接称该测试为“清单”，尽管有时也称其正式名称PCL-R，即“精神变态检查清单修订版”（Psychopathy Check List Revised）。
And to give you a sense of how the test is normally used, we have this story from Alix Spiegel.
为了让你了解该测试通常是如何使用的，我们有来自艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔的一篇报道。
The day that sealed Robert Dixon's fate began with a bike ride. Robert says it was still early morning when he asked his friend, a guy named John, to give him a ride home on the handlebars of his bike. But he says John was already upset. John had gotten into a fight with his girlfriend. He was jumpy and in a bad mood. So when they passed a young man headed in the opposite direction, Dixon says John made a proposal. Let's rob him.
决定罗伯特·狄克逊（Robert Dixon）命运的那一天，始于一次骑车出行。罗伯特说，那天清晨，他请他的朋友约翰载他一程，让他坐在自行车把手上回家。但他说约翰当时心情不好，正和女朋友吵架。他坐立不安，情绪极差。所以当他们经过一个迎面走来的年轻人时，狄克逊说约翰提议：抢劫他。
He said to me, he says, hey, let's see what this guy got. I said, no, come on, man, just take me home. He says, no, come on, let's just-- this ain't gonna take that long. So he turns the bike, and I'm sitting on the handlebars.
他对我说，嘿，看看这哥们有什么。我说，别闹了，伙计，送我回家吧。他说，不行，来吧，我们抢他——这花不了多长时间。于是他调转车头，我坐在车把上。
They caught up with the man, and Dixon jumped off the bike to act as lookout while John approached him, pulled out his gun, and asked for the guy's necklace. Dixon could hear them arguing. The man didn't want to give it up. He said it was a gift.
他们追上了那个人，狄克逊跳下自行车去放风，而约翰上前掏出枪，要求对方交出项链。狄克逊能听到他们在争吵。那个人不想交出来，说那是礼物。
Now, my main concern at this time is that I don't want to get caught doing what we're doing. So I'm looking around. I look at them. He's talking to him. Again, I'm looking around to see if the cops or anybody see us out there doing what we're doing. And pow! The gun goes off. What I saw, when I looked at my co-defendent, was shock, that he was in shock that he had just pulled that trigger. And so, I said what happened? He looked at me and he didn't answer me. He just ran.
当时我主要的担心是，不想在做坏事时被抓到。所以我四处张望。我看着他们，他在和那个人说话。我再次四处观察，看有没有警察或其他人看到我们在做什么。砰！枪响了。当我看向同伙时，我看到的是震惊，他对自己扣动扳机感到震惊。于是我问发生了什么？他看着我，没有回答，直接跑了。
In December of 1985, Robert Dixon got 15 years to life with a possibility of parole, for acting as an accessory to murder. Now, this was not Robert Dixon's first crime. There is no way to sugarcoat this. Robert Dixon was a delinquent. As a teen, he was convicted of raping one woman, and beating another. Since childhood, in fact, Dixon's life had been deeply disturbed. He tried to commit suicide at 10, and at 12, threatened to kill himself and his father, who, according to records, often beat him. He was in and out of detention for the rest of his teens. That was his life before the crime.
1985年12月，罗伯特·狄克逊因协助谋杀被判处15年至终身监禁，并有假释可能。这并不是罗伯特·狄克逊第一次犯罪。这一点无法掩盖。罗伯特·狄克逊是个少年犯。十几岁时，他曾因强奸一名女性和殴打另一名女性被定罪。事实上，从童年起，狄克逊的生活就一直动荡不安。他10岁时曾试图自杀，12岁时威胁要杀掉自己和父亲，据记录显示，他父亲经常殴打他。在随后的青少年时期，他进出拘留所多次。这就是他犯罪前的生活。
I'm just living day for day. I don't have a job. I've been kicked out of my home by my dad. He and I really not getting along. I'm ripping and running the streets. I was delinquent. I was a lost person.
我只是过一天算一天。我没有工作。我被父亲赶出了家门。我和他实在合不来。我在街上游荡、胡闹。我就是个少年犯。我是个迷失的人。
I went to interview Robert Dixon in a maximum security prison in Vacaville, California. 26 years later, he is still in prison for his crime. I went to see him because I wanted to understand who Robert Dixon is today. In the days before our meeting, I talked to a small army of his friends and family, all of whom felt, deep in their hearts, that they knew Robert Dixon, and that the man they knew was completely changed, that he was no longer a threat to anyone and was ready for parole. Here's Dixon's father, the man Robert once threatened to kill.
我前往加利福尼亚州瓦卡维尔的一所最高安全级别的监狱采访了罗伯特·狄克逊。26年后，他仍因罪在狱中服刑。我去见他，是因为我想了解今天的罗伯特·狄克逊是谁。在见面前的几天里，我采访了一群他的朋友和家人，他们内心深处都觉得他们了解罗伯特·狄克逊，认为他已经彻底改变了，不再对任何人构成威胁，已经准备好假释了。这是狄克逊的父亲，那个罗伯特曾威胁要杀掉的人。
I've seen him change in the last 10 years, drastic change in him, especially with me. He got older and he kind of slowed down, and I got older and I slowed down. Age change everybody.
在过去十年里，我看到了他的改变，巨大的改变，尤其是对我的态度。他年纪大了，人变得稳重了，我也老了，人也慢了下来。年龄改变了所有人。
Now, Dixon Senior says this transformation didn't happen quickly. He says for a time even after his son went to prison, he was still impulsive, still hard. Robert's early years behind bars were riddled with 115's. That's prison speak for rules violations. And the stories he would hear from Robert were always about fights. But about 12 years ago, he says, the narrative began to shift.
狄克逊先生说这种转变不是突然发生的。他说，甚至在他儿子入狱后的一段时间里，他仍然很冲动，依然强硬。罗伯特入狱后的头几年里，充满了“115记录”，这是监狱里关于违规行为的术语。他从罗伯特那里听到的故事总是关于打架。但他说，大约12年前，情况开始转变。
You know, he'd tell me about a lot of incidents that would come up and he would avoid them. You could have it your way, and walk away.
你知道，他会告诉我很多可能会发生的冲突，但他都避免了。你可以随心所欲，然后转身走开。
He knows that if he's going to get there, he's got to be twice as disciplined. He's got to do things above and beyond. And, quite frankly, he has.
他知道，如果他想重获自由，他就必须加倍自律。他必须超越自我，做到更好。坦白地说，他确实做到了。
This is Dixon's best friend, Bob Stuart. Like Dixon's father, when I went to visit Bob, he regaled me with stories of Dixon's transformation. And this change, Bob said, wasn't simply a matter of getting older and mellowing. Dixon, he said, had worked at it, worked at it hard. Bob brought out a folder with copies of Dixon's various certificates, from business courses, from self-help seminars, a thick stack documenting hours logged in a quest for change.
这是狄克逊最好的朋友，鲍勃·斯图尔特（Bob Stuart）。像狄克逊的父亲一样，当我去拜访鲍勃时，他向我讲述了狄克逊的转变故事。鲍勃说，这种改变不仅仅是年龄增长和性格柔和的问题。他说，狄克逊为此付出了努力，非常努力。鲍勃拿出一个文件夹，里面有狄克逊的各种证书复印件，包括商业课程、自助研讨会等，一叠厚厚的文件记录了他为寻求改变而投入的时间。
Stuart comes from a very different background than Dixon. He's a successful engineer who was introduced by a friend who met Dixon in prison and thought that Dixon could use a mentor. And at first, Stuart was just that, a mentor. But 16 years later, it's clear that that has changed.
斯图尔特的背景与狄克逊截然不同。他是一位成功的工程师，由一位在监狱认识狄克逊的朋友介绍，对方认为狄克逊需要一位导师。起初，斯图尔特确实扮演了那个角色。但16年后，情况显然发生了变化。
I mean, I consider him my best friend, and likewise. And hard to believe that somebody inside prison would be. And I have good friends, but he's the person I trust absolutely.
我是说，我把他当成我最好的朋友，他也一样。很难相信狱中人能成为这样的关系。我有好朋友，但他是我绝对信任的人。
Dixon's goal, Stuart told me, was not just to get out of prison, but once out, to do good. Dixon says the same.
斯图尔特告诉我，狄克逊的目标不仅仅是出狱，而且出狱后要多做好事。狄克逊也表达了同样的看法。
I'm not proud of my life. I've hurt people. I've disappointed myself. I've ruined my life. And I'm doing everything that I can to salvage some part of the second half of my life. So, yeah. I'm trying to turn it around.
我不为我的生活感到骄傲。我伤害过别人，让自己失望，毁了自己的生活。我正在竭尽全力挽救我后半生的某部分。所以，是的，我正在努力扭转局面。
So that's the way that Robert Dixon's friends and family see him, a man once bad, deeply reformed. But there's another view of Robert Dixon.
这就是罗伯特·狄克逊的朋友和家人眼中的他，一个曾经堕落但已彻底悔改的人。但对于罗伯特·狄克逊还有另一种看法。
Assessment for risk of violence.
暴力风险评估。
Dr. Peter Bradley is a psychologist in California who does forensic evaluations. And when I went to visit him, he showed me a stapled report with Dixon's name on top. The report was a psychological evaluation done by another psychologist, a psychologist employed by the state.
彼得·布拉德利博士（Dr. Peter Bradley）是加利福尼亚州的一名心理学家，专门从事法医评估工作。当我拜访他时，他向我展示了一份上面写着狄克逊名字的装订报告。这份报告是由另一位心理学家，一位受雇于州政府的心理学家所做的心理评估。
This is the main report that was done through the prison system.
这是通过监狱系统完成的主要报告。
You see, in California, before a lifer, like Dixon, goes in front of a parole board, they're given a psychological evaluation by a state psychologist. And as part of these evaluations, the prisoner is given a test to determine if they're a psychopath. All lifers up for parole in California are given the PCL-R.
你看，在加利福尼亚州，像狄克逊这样的无期徒刑犯在面对假释委员会之前，会由州政府的心理学家进行心理评估。作为评估的一部分，囚犯会接受一项测试，以确定他们是否为精神变态。所有在加州等待假释的无期徒刑犯都会接受PCL-R测试。
The Psychopathy Checklist Revised.
精神变态检查清单修订版。
Now, I want to say here that I did ask the California Department of Corrections to talk to me about Dixon's test. But they said no. Dr. Bradley, however, had reviewed Dixon's testing, and read to me from the report.
我想在这里说明，我确实要求加州惩教署就狄克逊的测试与我沟通，但他们拒绝了。不过，布拉德利博士审查了狄克逊的测试结果，并向我朗读了报告内容。
Mr. Dixon obtained a total score on the PCL-R which placed him in the high range of the clinical construct of psychopathy. He scored higher than 73% of those offenders on this instrument.
狄克逊先生在PCL-R上的总分将他置于精神变态临床结构的极高区间。他在该工具上的得分高于73%的罪犯。
That's very technical, probably hard to understand. What it means is this, that the psychologist saw Dixon not as a man reformed, but basically as a psychopath, as someone cold and remorseless, incapable of empathy, manipulative, narcissistic, impulsive, and therefore, as a person, likely bound by his very nature to do further violence. And it was really in large part because of his score on this test that Dixon was determined to be too high a risk and was denied parole at his last hearing.
这非常专业，可能很难理解。它的意思是：心理学家认为狄克逊不是一个改过自新的人，本质上是一个精神变态者，一个冷酷无情、缺乏同理心、具有操纵欲、自恋、冲动的人，因此，从本质上讲，他极有可能再次实施暴力。正是因为他在该测试中的得分，狄克逊被认为风险过高，并在最近一次听证会上被拒绝假释。
So which Robert Dixon is the real Robert Dixon, the one the test sees, or the one that his friends and family see? To answer that question, you need to understand more about the test, the man who created it, and how it came to have so much power.
那么，哪一个罗伯特·狄克逊才是真正的罗伯特·狄克逊？是测试眼中那个，还是他朋友和家人眼中那个？要回答这个问题，你需要更多地了解这项测试，了解它的创造者，以及它如何获得如此大的权力。
[SINGING] So, what? A classroom of people watches this video?
[歌唱] 所以呢？一个教室里的人在看这个视频？
No, maybe a couple.
不，可能就几个。
This is taped from one of more than 1,000 interviews collected by the creator of the PCL-R, the Canadian psychologist, Robert Hare. All of the interviews are with prisoners, many of whom, like this man, are psychopaths.
这是PCL-R的创造者，加拿大心理学家罗伯特·黑尔（Robert Hare）收集的1000多个访谈中的一段录像。所有访谈的对象都是囚犯，其中许多人，像这个人一样，都是精神变态者。
Anyway, I was going on about justifiable murder. Someone rapes your wife, molests your kid. And then a guy's got to do that. If he doesn't-- that's just the way it goes. An eye for an eye, a tooth for a tooth. Yea, though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death I will fear no evil, for I pack a .357 Magnum.
不管怎样，我一直在谈论所谓的正当谋杀。如果有人强奸了你妻子，猥亵了你孩子，那么一个人就不得不动手。如果他不这样做——事情就是这样。以眼还眼，以牙还牙。我虽行过死荫的幽谷，也不怕遭害，因为我随身带着.357麦格农手枪。
I visited Hare at his home in Canada, and together we watched videos like this for hours, psychopath after psychopath, one after another.
我拜访了住在加拿大的黑尔，我们一起看了好几个小时这样的录像，一个接一个的精神变态者。
I've got so much great stuff in here. This guy's terrific. He's part of the New York mob.
我这里有太多精彩的内容了。这家伙太棒了。他是纽约黑手党成员。
I was upset that he didn't want to pay me the money. He had the nerve.
他不想付钱给我，我很生气。他居然有胆量这么做。
Hare would play some tape, then stop and talk about language use and psychopaths, or pain and psychopaths. And as he watched, there was always this glimmer in his eye. It was impossible to ignore the pleasure he got from watching them.
黑尔会播放一些录像，然后停下来谈论精神变态者的语言使用，或者精神变态者对痛苦的感受。当他观看时，他的眼里总闪烁着光芒。你无法忽视他从观看这些内容中获得的快感。
Like, there's a smile on your face.
你看，你脸上带着笑容。
Oh, that's gas pains. In spite of the fact that I've been in this game for a long time, I'm still-- it's a source of amazement.
哦，那是胃胀气。尽管我从事这个行业已经很久了，但我依然——这仍然令人惊叹。
Hare has been in this game a long time. He began studying psychopaths in the 1960s. And it's easy to forget now, in part because Hare's work has made the idea of the psychopath so commonplace, but back then, research on psychopaths was totally obscure. And no one, least of all Bob Hare, thought that this work on psychopaths would ever have any practical applications.
黑尔在这一行干了很久。他从20世纪60年代开始研究精神变态者。现在可能很容易被忽略，因为黑尔的工作使“精神变态”这个概念变得如此普遍，但在当时，关于精神变态的研究完全处于边缘地位。没有人，尤其是鲍勃·黑尔自己，认为这项工作会有任何实际应用。
What Bob was interested in was basic science. He wanted to understand what made psychopaths tick. To figure this out, he went to a place he figured he'd find at least some psychopaths, a prison 30 miles away from his office at the University of British Columbia. And he asked the prisoners for their help.
鲍勃感兴趣的是基础科学。他想了解精神变态者的行为机制。为了弄明白这一点，他去了他认为至少能找到一些精神变态者的地方——离他在不列颠哥伦比亚大学办公室30英里远的一所监狱。他请求囚犯们提供帮助。
And the offenders in those days had hardly ever been studied. They were very interested in what I was doing. And they would all volunteer, and, in fact, one of the head inmates there, the one at the very top of the heap, actually held a public address. In those days, they could congregate in groups of 400 or 500. And said, look, this sounds interesting. I'm in. And everybody else then said, we're in, too.
那时候这些罪犯几乎从未被研究过。他们对我所做的事情非常感兴趣。他们全都自告奋勇，事实上，监狱里的一位领头人物，地位最高的那位，还主持了一次公开演讲。在那些日子里，他们可以400到500人聚在一起。他说，看，这听起来很有趣。我参加。然后其他人也都说，我们也参加。
So Hare set up a lab and started pumping out studies. For example, Hare would place the prisoners in a chair, tell them that in 30 seconds, he was going to zap them with an electrical shock, then measure their heart rate to see if that information bothered them.
于是黑尔建立了一个实验室，并开始产出研究成果。例如，黑尔会让囚犯坐在椅子上，告诉他们30秒后要给他们电击，然后测量他们的心率，看看这个信息是否会让他们感到困扰。
Most showed lots of emotional arousal, anticipatory fear, anxiety, while they're waiting for the shock to occur. Psychopaths, hardly any.
大多数人会表现出大量的情绪唤起、预期恐惧和焦虑，在等待电击时。而精神变态者几乎毫无反应。
In another experiment, Hare showed the prisoners both highly emotional and totally neutral pictures-- a picture of a rape, say, versus the picture of a chair-- and again measured their physical response. He found that, for most prisoners, the emotional pictures prompted a very different reaction than the pictures of a table or chair.
在另一个实验中，黑尔向囚犯展示了高度情绪化和完全中性的图片——比如一张强奸的照片与一张椅子的照片——并再次测量了他们的生理反应。他发现，对于大多数囚犯来说，情绪化的图片会引发与桌椅图片截然不同的反应。
But with psychopaths, there's no difference. They treat these horrific pictures as if they were neutral pictures. No difference, whatsoever, between them.
但对于精神变态者，两者没有区别。他们对待这些恐怖的图片就像对待中性图片一样。两者之间没有任何区别。
And over the course of these experiments, Hare developed a theory. He believed that the psychopaths he saw were, essentially, emotionally deaf, simply did not have the capacity to feel, in a first-hand way, emotions like empathy, remorse, and love.
在这些实验过程中，黑尔发展出了一套理论。他认为他所见的精神变态者在本质上是“情感聋子”，根本没有能力直接体验同理心、悔意和爱等情感。
It's sort of like trying to explain to a color blind person what the color red is. Can we teach a color blind person how to see red, what red is? You can have all the dictionary definitions you want, but this person will never quite get it.
这就像试图向一个色盲解释什么是红色一样。我们能教色盲如何看到红色吗？你可以用尽字典里的所有定义，但这个人永远无法完全理解。
Now, this work was basically well received. But Hare says there was still a huge amount of skepticism. Part of the problem stemmed from the fact that this field of research, psychopathy research, was lacking one very important ingredient. You see, in science, before you can do practically anything, there is one thing you absolutely, positively, have to get straight.
这项工作基本受到了好评。但黑尔说，仍存在巨大的怀疑。部分问题源于精神变态研究这一领域缺乏一个非常重要的要素。你看，在科学界，在你能做几乎任何事情之前，有一件事你绝对必须搞清楚。
The key is measurement. Science cannot progress without reliable and accurate measurement of what it is they're trying to study. Simple as that.
关键在于测量。如果没有对研究对象可靠且准确的测量，科学就无法进步。就是这么简单。
To understand this, consider for a moment the blood pressure cuff. Hare says before the blood pressure cuff was invented in 1881, doctors had no good way of figuring out if someone had high blood pressure or low blood pressure, which meant they couldn't figure out that high blood pressure was related to heart attacks, and all sorts of seriously unfortunate things. Here, Hare concluded, was the problem with his field as well. There was simply no way to measure.
要理解这一点，考虑一下血压计。黑尔说，在血压计于1881年发明之前，医生没有好办法判断一个人是否患有高血压或低血压，这意味着他们无法发现高血压与心脏病以及各种严重不幸事件之间的联系。黑尔认为，这就是他研究领域的问题。根本没有测量方法。
We did not have the psychiatric equivalent of the blood pressure cuff.
我们没有心理学版的血压计。
And so, Hare decided to make one. He sat down with his long-term research assistant, and together they wrote down all of the personality traits that they and other scientists had consistently seen in the psychopaths they studied, traits like, well, like these, read by Hare and a former student of his, Steve Hart, who is now a leader in the field.
于是，黑尔决定制造一个。他与他的长期研究助理坐在一起，写下了他和科学家们在研究对象中一致观察到的所有人格特征。这些特征由黑尔和他的一位前学生史蒂夫·哈特（Steve Hart）——如今该领域的领军人物——朗读出来。
Egocentricity, grandiose sense of self-worth.
自我中心，狂妄的自我价值感。
Pathological lying, cunning, manipulative.
病态撒谎，狡猾，操纵欲。
Lack of sincerity, lack of remorse or guilt, lack of empathy.
缺乏真诚，缺乏悔意或内疚，缺乏同理心。
Sensation seeking or proneness to boredom, failure to accept responsibility for own actions, and so forth.
寻求刺激或容易感到无聊，逃避个人行为责任，等等。
Now, for each of these traits, Hare wrote up a little description so that people would know what he meant by, say, lack of empathy. Psychologists using the test were supposed to ask the interview subject a series of questions about their criminal history, their family, to determine whether the person had that quality.
现在，针对这些特征中的每一项，黑尔都写了一小段描述，以便人们能明白他所指的“缺乏同理心”是什么意思。使用该测试的心理学家需要询问受试者一系列关于犯罪历史、家庭的问题，以确定该人是否具备这些特质。
Parasitic lifestyle.
寄生生活方式。
If the trait was present, they got a two. Absent, they got a zero. And if it wasn't really clear, they got a one. There were 20 traits to check, which is why Hare calls it the Check List, and at the end of the test, your score was totaled. 40 was the highest you could get, but anything over 30 certified you as a psychopath. Voila, the PCL-R was born. It was 1980. At his house, Hare pulled out an ancient-looking document.
如果特征存在，得2分。缺失，得0分。如果不确定，得1分。共有20个特征需要核对，这就是为什么黑尔将其称为“检查清单”。测试结束时，总分会被加起来。最高分为40分，但任何超过30分的分数就足以将你认证为精神变态。瞧，PCL-R诞生了。那是1980年。在家里，黑尔拿出了一份看起来很古老的文件。
So this is literally it.
这就是原件。
This is it. This is the first thing that people saw. 17 pages, double spaced.
就是这个。这是人们第一次看到的东西。17页，双倍行距。
A certified diagnostic test, which at least appeared to be remarkably reliable. When two different testers gave the test to the same person, they usually got the same result. The PCL-R was on its way. Kind of. Actually, the only people really interested in his test at this point, in the early '80s, were other academic researchers. People in the criminal justice community still saw the study of psychopaths as marginal, irrelevant to understanding crime. You see, at the time, criminal justice people thought about where crime came from in a very specific way. Criminals were made, not born.
一项经过认证的诊断测试，至少看起来非常可靠。当两个不同的测试者对同一个人进行测试时，通常会得到相同的结果。PCL-R就这样开始流行了。其实，在80年代初期，真正对这项测试感兴趣的人只有其他学术研究人员。刑事司法界的人仍然认为精神变态研究是边缘性的，与理解犯罪无关。你看，当时，刑事司法人员对犯罪来源的看法非常具体。罪犯是环境塑造的，而非天生的。
Criminologists, sociologists, tended to explain crime in terms of environmental factors, where you were raised, who your family was, your peer group. So in those days, social factors, environmental factors, were the explanation for all crime.
犯罪学家、社会学家倾向于从环境因素来解释犯罪，即你的成长环境、家庭、同伴群体。所以那时候，社会因素、环境因素是所有犯罪的解释。
The idea was that anybody could be bad, or good. It was all the environment. And Hare's focus on personality didn't really fit this zeitgeist. But the disinterest of the criminal justice community changed almost overnight, after one of Hare's students, an undergrad, proposed to do a study. What the student wanted to do was see what happened to prisoners who had been tested after they were released from prison. Was a person with a high score on the PCL-R more likely to commit a crime than a person with a low score? Turns out, they were. Bob Hare.
当时的想法是，任何人都可以变坏，也可以变好。全由环境决定。黑尔对人格的关注并没有真正融入这种时代思潮。但刑事司法界的不感兴趣几乎在一夜之间改变了，在黑尔的一位本科生提出要进行一项研究之后。该学生想看看囚犯在服刑期满释放后会发生什么。PCL-R高分者是否比低分者更容易再次犯罪？事实证明，确实如此。鲍勃·黑尔。
Those who had low scores on the PCL-R, about 20% or 25% would be reconvicted within four or five years. The high group was 80%.
那些PCL-R得分低的人，大约20%或25%会在四五年内再次被定罪。而高分群体比例是80%。
So score high, and there was an 80% chance you would re-offend. Score low, 20%. In other words--
所以得分高，再次犯罪的几率是80%。得分低，是20%。换句话说——
The checklist did an excellent job of predicting who would commit another offense within the next couple of years.
清单在预测谁会在接下来的几年内再次犯罪方面做得非常出色。
How excellent a job?
出色到什么程度？
As good as one could get.
能达到的最好程度。
This was a huge finding. For years, criminologists had labored to dissect the environmental causes of crime. Then, suddenly, here was the PCL-R, a personality test, used for marginal academic research, that appeared to identify the world's most serious chronic criminals, the people we really needed to worry about. Steve Hart, Bob's former student, says that everybody was shocked.
这是一个巨大的发现。多年来，犯罪学家一直致力于剖析环境对犯罪的影响。突然间，PCL-R出现了，这原本是用于边缘学术研究的人格测试，却似乎能识别出世界上最严重的慢性罪犯，那些我们真正需要担心的群体。史蒂夫·哈特，鲍勃的前学生，说当时每个人都感到震惊。
Here we are, using a diagnosis of personality disorder to predict criminal behavior, and it's working. And it's working in a way that's obvious. You could see the differences. An old psychologist, Jacob Cohen, called this the intraocular effect, like it just really hit you between the eyes.
我们竟然在利用人格障碍诊断来预测犯罪行为，而且奏效了。而且它的奏效方式显而易见。你可以看到差异。一位资深心理学家雅各布·科恩（Jacob Cohen）称此为“眼内效应”，就像它直击你的眼球一样。
The paper was first publicized in the mid-'80s, and people in the criminal justice community quickly came calling. For example, Steve Hart remembers that shortly after the paper went public, the lab got a visit from Canada's National Parole Board. They wanted the test.
该论文在80年代中期首次公开，刑事司法界的人迅速打来电话。例如，史蒂夫·哈特记得论文发表后不久，实验室就收到了加拿大国家假释委员会的来访。他们想要这项测试。
They said, quite literally, what we want to do is give everybody this test, and then have the test score written in big red numbers on the front of the file. No parole board should be able to make a decision without having some knowledge about whether or not somebody is psychopathic.
他们直言不讳地说，我们想要做的就是让每个人都接受这项测试，然后把测试分数用大红数字写在档案首页。没有任何假释委员会应该在不知道某人是否患有精神变态的情况下做出决定。
I think most of the researchers in the room were horrified, that, no, we don't want that.
我想在座的大多数研究人员都惊恐万分，心想，不，我们不希望那样。
Adelle Forth is another researcher who worked in the lab.
阿德尔·福思（Adelle Forth）是另一位在实验室工作的研究人员。
The idea that you would just stamp something on someone's file would be horrific, because this label, someone is a psychopath, this will stay with this individual. This is not something that will go away.
仅仅在某人的档案上盖个章的想法太可怕了，因为一旦贴上“精神变态”的标签，就会伴随这个人一生。这不是会消失的东西。
In fact, every researcher that I spoke to who was there at first found this idea of parole boards using the test deeply disturbing, including the guy who invented the thing, Robert Hare.
事实上，我采访过的每一位当时在场的研究人员，都觉得假释委员会使用这项测试的想法令人深感不安，包括发明它的罗伯特·黑尔本人。
The potential for misuse of an instrument that has solid scientific credentials is very great. And the reason is, people say, well, it's got solid scientific credentials. It's really, really good. It must be good. So my apprehensions were there from the very, very beginning, about the potential for misuse.
滥用一种具有扎实科学凭证的工具的可能性是非常巨大的。原因在于，人们会说，既然它有扎实的科学凭证，肯定很好，很棒。所以，从一开始，我就对滥用的可能性感到担忧。
And so, at least initially after the criminal justice people came calling, Hare was clear. Hare said they weren't getting his test. Steve Hart.
因此，至少在刑事司法人员上门初期，黑尔态度明确。黑尔说他们得不到这项测试。史蒂夫·哈特。
I'm never giving the checklist to somebody who works in the criminal justice system. I'm just going to give it to scientists who do nothing, as opposed to people who actually try to make decisions. And we actually had a lot of value or moral discussions about that, about would it be appropriate to withhold the information from people who might try to use it?
我永远不会把清单交给刑事司法系统的人。我只会把它给那些不做任何决定的科学家，而不是那些试图做决策的人。我们当时确实就此进行了很多价值或道德上的讨论，关于扣留这些信息是否合适？
And so, for many years, Hare refused requests from the criminal justice system. But Hart says Hare's students argued with him, told him that this was simply not his choice to make, that scientists don't really have a right to withhold knowledge once that knowledge exists.
所以多年来，黑尔拒绝了刑事司法系统的请求。但哈特说，黑尔的学生与他争论，告诉他这根本不是他能决定的，科学家一旦掌握了知识，就没有权利扣留它。
Like, you know, come on, buddy. Free it up. If you've got something important, then let's let everybody take a look at this.
就像是，算了吧，哥们。放手吧。如果你有重要的东西，那就让大家都看看吧。
Eventually, Hare agreed, and in 1991 he published the PCL-R officially, so that anyone could use it, including people in the criminal justice system, which is how the test ended up being used in America, on people like Robert Dixon.
最终，黑尔同意了，并于1991年正式发布了PCL-R，以便任何人都可以使用它，包括刑事司法系统中的人。这就是该测试最终如何在美国被使用，用在像罗伯特·狄克逊这样的人身上。
I remember reading the report, and feeling heartbroken.
我记得读那份报告时感到心碎。
This is Charles Carbone, Robert Dixon's lawyer, talking about a day two years ago, when Robert's psychological report arrived in the mail.
这是查尔斯·卡博恩（Charles Carbone），罗伯特·狄克逊的律师，他在谈论两年前罗伯特的心理报告寄到时的那一天。
I knew, no matter how hard I worked from that day forward, that when I brought him back to board, we were going to get denied.
我知道，无论我那天之后怎么努力，当我把他带回委员会时，我们都会被拒绝。
The political reality, Carbone says, is this. In California, not only the board, but the governor must sign off on every parole granted. And there's just no benefit to being seen as soft on crime. So if a psychologist gives a bad report because of a high score on the psychopath test, even if the board or the governor wanted to set that person free, there is, as Carbone points out, no political cover if the prisoner re-offends.
卡博恩说，政治现实是这样的：在加利福尼亚州，不仅委员会，州长也必须签署每一项批准的假释。而被视为“对犯罪软弱”是没有任何好处的。所以，如果一位心理学家因为精神变态测试的高分而给出一份负面报告，即使委员会或州长想释放那个人，正如卡博恩所指出的，如果囚犯再次犯罪，也没有政治掩护。
The headline will be, well, the psychologist told you so. There is no political upside. They only have something to lose by allowing these lifers to go home.
头条新闻会写：心理学家早就提醒过你了。这样做没有任何政治收益。允许这些无期徒刑犯回家，他们只有损失。
Which is why so few people with Robert Dixon's test scores ever do go home. Still, Carbone is trying to fight it. He hired Dr. Peter Bradley, the forensic psychologist you heard from earlier, who evaluated Dixon, and like his friends and family, concluded that he is not a psychopath.
这就是为什么很少有像罗伯特·狄克逊这样得分的人能回家。尽管如此，卡博恩还是试图抗争。他聘请了之前提到的法医心理学家彼得·布拉德利博士，他对狄克逊进行了评估，并像他的朋友和家人一样，结论是他不是精神变态。
That he has developed, among other things, a sense of caring and ability to be compassionate with other people, that he's matured in that way.
他认为狄克逊，除其他因素外，已经培养出了一种关怀感和对他人的同情能力，他在这些方面已经成熟了。
Dr. Bradley says, in general, he doesn't like to use the PCL-R, because he feels the scoring of the test is determined too much by events in the past that prisoners can't change, by juvenile delinquency, and things that happened in school, an inmate's criminal past, not who they are today.
布拉德利博士说，总的来说，他不喜欢使用PCL-R，因为他觉得该测试的得分过多地取决于囚犯无法改变的过去事件，比如青少年犯罪、学校里发生的事情、囚犯的犯罪记录，而不是现在的他们。
It's weighted more toward the historical factors. It's not able to look at factors that can change and that do tend to change with a lot of people.
它的权重更多地偏向历史因素。它无法查看那些可以改变，且往往会随许多人而改变的因素。
This is what Dr. Bradley thinks has happened to Robert Dixon. He thinks Dixon's changed substantially, but will always get a high score because Dixon had a long criminal record before he went to prison. As for Dixon, he doesn't know why he's doing so badly. He says his friends and family don't understand either. They keep asking him what's happening.
这就是布拉德利博士认为发生在罗伯特·狄克逊身上的情况。他认为狄克逊已经发生了实质性的改变，但因为在入狱前有长期犯罪记录，他将永远得到高分。至于狄克逊，他不知道自己为什么表现得这么糟糕。他说他的朋友和家人也不明白。他们一直在问他发生了什么。
What are you going to here saying to these people? I says, hey, I'm talking to them just like I'm talking to you. I'm not switching up here. This is not Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde. I don't know what's going on.
你打算对这些人说什么？我说，嘿，我和他们说话就像和你说话一样。我没有演戏。这不是化身博士（Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde）。我不知道发生了什么。
Now, obviously, Dixon's friends and family could be wrong. Robert Dixon could be a psychopath. But I will tell you that in recent years, use of the test in the criminal justice system has come under criticism. And you know who's one of the people criticizing? Robert Hare. He tells me that some of his initial fears about how the test might be misused have actually come to pass.
显然，狄克逊的朋友和家人可能是错的。罗伯特·狄克逊可能确实是个精神变态。但我可以告诉你，近年来，该测试在刑事司法系统中的使用受到了批评。你知道其中一位批评者是谁吗？罗伯特·黑尔。他告诉我，他最初关于测试可能被滥用的担忧实际上已经成为现实。
I feel ambivalent about it.
我对此感到矛盾。
You see, while Hare's a strong believer that his test works well for the basic lab research that it was originally designed for, he, like others, has begun to wonder if the test does as good a job outside the lab.
你看，虽然黑尔坚信他的测试对于最初设计的基础实验室研究非常有效，但他和其他人一样，开始怀疑该测试在实验室外是否同样出色。
Once you get into the real world, there does seem to be some lessening of reliability.
一旦进入现实世界，可靠性似乎确实有所下降。
This is Daniel Murray, a professor at the University of Virginia. About four years ago, Murray did a study which looked at what happened when a psychologist hired by the prosecution gave the test to the same prisoner as a psychologist hired by the defense. Did those two psychologists give the same score to the same person? The answer? Definitively no.
这是丹尼尔·默里（Daniel Murray），弗吉尼亚大学的一位教授。大约四年前，默里进行了一项研究，调查了当检方聘请的心理学家和辩方聘请的心理学家对同一名囚犯进行测试时发生了什么。这两位心理学家会给同一个人打出相同的分数吗？答案是：绝对没有。
10, 15, even 20 point score differences we found. And overall, there was about an eight-point difference in scores.
我们发现了10分、15分甚至20分的分数差异。总体而言，得分差异平均有8分。
In fact, in 2/3 of the cases, the scores were substantially different. And the differences were not random. Psychologists hired by the prosecution consistently scored people higher, found more psychopaths. Psychologists hired by the defense scored people lower, found fewer psychopaths, as you might expect. But there's something else which might explain these differences that Murray found. There's no regulation of who can administer this test. Hare tells me that he often does training in America, and says he frequently sees things that, frankly, horrify him: people without degrees in psychology using the test, poorly trained people using the test.
事实上，在三分之二的案例中，得分存在实质性差异。而且这些差异并非随机。检方聘请的心理学家始终给出的得分较高，发现了更多的精神变态者。辩方聘请的心理学家给出的得分较低，发现了较少的精神变态者，正如你所预料的那样。但还有其他因素可能解释默里发现的这些差异。谁可以管理这项测试没有任何规定。黑尔告诉我，他经常在美国进行培训，并表示他经常看到一些让他坦率地说感到恐惧的事情：没有心理学学位的人在使用测试，受过劣质训练的人在使用测试。
Many of these people have really no business doing this. It would be sort of like asking a nurse now to go out and start performing surgery. It doesn't work this way. It shouldn't work that way. So I'm very concerned about the inappropriate, unprofessional use of this instrument for purposes that have serious implications for the individual and for society.
这些人中的许多人根本没资格做这件事。这就像让护士现在就开始做手术一样。这行不通。不应该是这样的。所以我对将此工具不恰当、不专业地用于对个人和社会产生严重后果的目的感到非常担忧。
Do you think that, on an emotional level, like it's hard for you emotionally to think about your instrument having hurt somebody?
你认为在情感层面上，想到你的工具伤害了某人，你在情感上感到困难吗？
Oh, yeah. Interesting question. Notice I didn't say that's a good question. Interesting question. Almost certainly. I think about this periodically, and I probably try to suppress it. Yeah, I do dissociate myself from it. If I thought of every potential use or misuse of the instrument, I probably wouldn't sleep at all.
哦，是的。有趣的问题。注意我没说这是一个好问题。是有趣的问题。几乎可以肯定。我定期思考这个问题，我可能试图压制它。是的，我确实将自己与它脱钩。如果我考虑该工具的每一个潜在用途或滥用，我可能根本无法入睡。
OK, are we going to the bedroom, or here stay?
好的，我们要去卧室，还是留在这？
Of course, the friends and family of Robert Dixon are convinced that there's been a misuse of the test. And convinced, too, that that error will somehow miraculously be corrected. When I went to visit Robert's father at his home, he took me down a hallway and showed me a neatly prepared, fully equipped second bedroom. It was, he told me, for Robert.
当然，罗伯特·狄克逊的朋友和家人确信这项测试被滥用了。并且同样确信，那个错误会以某种奇迹般的方式得到纠正。当我拜访罗伯特的父亲时，他带着我走进走廊，展示了一间布置整齐、设备齐全的次卧室。他说，那是为罗伯特准备的。
OK, this is his room. There's a bed. There's a closet. This would be his dresser.
好，这是他的房间。有床。有衣柜。这是他的梳妆台。
As I said before, for most of their lives, these two men had grave difficulties. But now, every other Sunday, Dixon Senior goes to visit Dixon Junior in prison. They talk about what they're going to do when Robert gets out. They want to go fishing together. Dixon Senior already bought the gear. And as I listen to them talk about these conversations and the relationship they have, it's hard to believe that it's a con, that it's cold-blooded manipulation. They seem very close, just as Robert seems very close to his best friend. And I found myself wondering if a true psychopath could really have relationships like this.
正如我之前所说，这两个人一生中大部分时间都处境艰难。但现在，每隔一个星期天，狄克逊先生都会去监狱探望狄克逊。他们谈论罗伯特出狱后要做什么。他们想一起去钓鱼。狄克逊先生已经买好了装备。当我听着他们谈论这些对话以及他们之间的关系时，很难相信这是一场骗局，是冷血的操纵。他们看起来非常亲密，就像罗伯特与他最好的朋友看起来非常亲密一样。我发现自己不禁想，一个真正的精神变态者真的能有这样的关系吗？
Do you think you're going to get out of here?
你认为你能从这里出去吗？
I hope so. I hope so. And I hope I can get out before my dad pass away.
希望如此。希望如此。我希望能在父亲去世前出去。
Yeah, well, better hurry up. And I'll be here waiting for him.
好吧，最好快点。我会在这里等他。
Robert Dixon Junior has been incarcerated for being an accessory to murder for 26 years. In 2014, he will have a new parole hearing. If he goes to that hearing with his current score on the psychopath test, which he is slated to do, it's very likely that Robert Dixon will be denied.
罗伯特·狄克逊因协助谋杀罪已入狱26年。2014年，他将面临新的假释听证会。如果他带着目前在精神变态测试中的得分参加那次听证会，按计划他确实要去，那么罗伯特·狄克逊很可能会被拒绝。
Alix Spiegel. She's a science correspondent for NPR News. Coming up, the positive side of being a psychopath. Jon Ronson on how being a psychopath can help you in your business. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔，NPR新闻科学记者。接下来，精神变态者的积极一面。乔恩·罗森将谈论成为精神变态者如何能在事业上帮助你。一分钟后，由芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台联合播出的节目继续进行。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show is all about the psychopath test, created by Bob Hare, used around the world by courtrooms, and prisons, and this week by us as well. We took the test. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, King of the Forest.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目全部关于精神变态测试，由鲍勃·黑尔创造，在世界各地的法庭和监狱中使用，本周我们也使用了它。我们接受了测试。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，森林之王。
Jon Ronson has a new book out about the psychopath test. In fact, that's the name of the book. It's called The Psychopath Test . In his research, Jon met with Bob Hare, who created the test. He also went to a seminar, to learn to administer the test himself, which had an unfortunate effect on Jon. He started seeing all kinds of people as psychopaths. It really is everywhere if you start to look for it.
乔恩·罗森有一本关于精神变态测试的新书。事实上，那本书的名字就叫《精神变态测试》（The Psychopath Test）。在他的研究中，乔恩见到了创造该测试的鲍勃·黑尔。他还去参加了一个研讨会，学习自己进行测试，这给乔恩带来了一个不幸的后果。他开始把各种各样的人都看作精神变态。如果你开始寻找，它确实无处不在。
Jon saw this statistic. 1% of the general population tests as psychopath, 25% of the US prison population, which makes sense, I guess, and 4%-- 4%-- of business leaders. Ronson wondered if that could possibly be true, that so many business leaders might have psychopathic traits. And so, he tried to find a business leader who might prove this true or false. And then he learned about a former chief executive of Sunbeam, the toaster and appliance company.
乔恩看到了这个统计数据：普通人群中1%为精神变态，美国监狱人口中25%为精神变态，我想这说得通，以及4%——4%——的商业领袖。罗森怀疑这是否可能是真的，这么多商业领袖可能具有精神变态特征。于是，他试图寻找一位可能证明此结论真假的商业领袖。然后他了解到了太阳能（Sunbeam）烤面包机和电器公司的一位前首席执行官。
In the mid-1990s, Sunbeam was a mess. The board of directors needed a merciless cost-cutter. And so, they offered the job to someone quite unique, a man who seemed to actually, unlike most humans, enjoy firing people. His name was Al Dunlap, and he'd made his reputation closing down plants on behalf of Scott, America's oldest toilet paper manufacturer. There were countless stories of him going from Scott plant to Scott plant firing people in amusing, sometimes eerie ways. At a plant in Mobile, Alabama, for instance, he asked a man how long he'd worked there. "30 years," the man proudly replied. "Why would you want to stay at a company for 30 years?" Dunlap said, looking genuinely perplexed. A few weeks later, he closed the Mobile plant down, firing everyone.
90年代中期，太阳能公司一团糟。董事会需要一个无情的成本削减者。于是他们把工作提供给了一个非常独特的人，一个不像大多数人类那样，似乎真的乐于解雇员工的人。他的名字叫艾尔·邓拉普（Al Dunlap），他因代表美国最古老的卫生纸制造商斯科特（Scott）关闭工厂而闻名。关于他从一家斯科特工厂奔向另一家工厂，用有趣、有时令人毛骨悚然的方式解雇员工的故事不胜枚举。例如，在阿拉巴马州莫比尔市的一家工厂，他问一个人在那里工作了多久。“30年了，”那人骄傲地回答。“你为什么要留在一个公司30年？”邓拉普问，看起来真的很困惑。几周后，他关闭了莫比尔工厂，解雇了所有人。
He fired people with such apparent glee, that the business magazine Fast Company included him in an article about potentially psychopathic CEOs. All the other CEOs cited were dead or in prison, and therefore unlikely to sue. But they took the plunge with Dunlap anyway. They referred to his poor behavioral controls. His first wife charged in her divorce papers that he once threatened her with a knife and muttered that he always wondered what human flesh tasted like. Then there was his lack of empathy. Even though he was always telling journalists about his wise and supportive parents, he didn't turn up at either of their funerals.
他解雇员工时流露出的那种明显快感，使得商业杂志《快公司》（Fast Company）将他列入了一篇关于潜在精神变态CEO的文章中。文中提到的其他所有CEO要么已去世，要么在监狱中，因此不太可能起诉。但他们还是对邓拉普冒险了。他们提到了他较差的行为控制能力。他的第一任妻子在离婚文件中指控他曾用刀威胁她，并嘀咕着他一直想知道人肉是什么味道。还有他缺乏同理心。尽管他总是向记者吹嘘他那英明支持他的父母，但他却从未出现在他们任何人的葬礼上。
On the July 1996 day that Sunbeam's board of directors revealed the name of their new CEO, their share price skyrocketed, from $12.50 to $18.63. Dunlap went on a year-long rampage across rural America, firing 12,000 employees, and closing plants in Shubuta and Bay Springs and Laurel, Mississippi, and Cookeville, Tennessee, and Coushatta, Louisiana. And on and on, turning communities across the American south into ghost towns. With each plant closure, the Sunbeam share price soared, reaching an incredible $51.00.
1996年7月，太阳能董事会公布新任CEO名字的那一天，他们的股价飙升，从12.50美元涨至18.63美元。邓拉普随后在整个美国乡村进行了一年的疯狂裁员，解雇了12,000名员工，关闭了密西西比州舒布塔、贝湾泉、劳雷尔，田纳西州库克维尔以及路易斯安那州库沙塔等地的工厂。诸如此类，将美国南方各地的社区变成了鬼城。随着每家工厂的关闭，太阳能的股价都在飙升，达到惊人的51美元。
I emailed his personal assistant-cum-bodyguard, Sean Thornton. I said there's a theory shared by neurologists all over the world that the brains of certain highly successful people literally work differently to ordinary people's brains. It's basically all to do with the amygdala shooting signals of fear down to the central nervous system. The theory goes that very highly successful people, like Mr. Dunlap, are literally fearless, because the amygdala doesn't shoot those signals. I didn't mention in the email that psychiatrists call that brain anomaly psychopathy. They said I was welcome to come over.
我给他的私人助理兼保镖肖恩·桑顿（Sean Thornton）发了电子邮件。我说，世界各地的神经学家都有一个共同的理论，即某些非常成功的人的大脑与普通人的大脑工作方式完全不同。这一切基本上都与杏仁核向中枢神经系统发射恐惧信号有关。该理论认为，像邓拉普先生这样非常成功的人，字面意义上是无畏的，因为杏仁核没有发出那些信号。我没在邮件里提到精神病学家称这种大脑异常为精神变态。他们说欢迎我过去。
This first obviously strange thing about Al Dunlap's grand Florida mansion and lavish manicured lawns was the unusually large number of ferocious sculptures there were of predatory animals. They were everywhere. Stone lions and panthers with teeth bared, eagles soaring downward, hawks with fish in their talons, and on and on, across the grounds, around the lake, in the swimming pool health club complex, in the many rooms. There were crystal lions, and onyx lions, and iron lions, and iron panthers, and paintings of lions, and sculptures of human skulls.
关于艾尔·邓拉普豪华的佛罗里达豪宅和修剪整齐的华丽草坪，第一件明显奇怪的事情就是那里有大量凶猛的捕食性动物雕塑。它们到处都是。张开牙齿的石狮子和黑豹，向下俯冲的老鹰，爪子里抓着鱼的鹰，等等，遍布场地，环绕湖泊，在游泳池健身中心，在许多房间里。有水晶狮子，黑玛瑙狮子，铁狮子和铁黑豹，还有狮子的画作和人头骨雕塑。
"Lions," said Al Dunlap, showing me around. He's wearing a casual jacket and slacks, and looking tanned, healthy. His teeth were very white. "Lions, jaguars, lions. Always predators. Predators, predators, predators. I have a great belief in and a great respect for predators. Everything I did, I had to go make happen."
“狮子，”艾尔·邓拉普说，带着我四处参观。他穿着休闲夹克和长裤，看起来晒成棕褐色，很健康。他的牙齿非常白。“狮子，美洲虎，狮子。永远是捕食者。捕食者，捕食者，捕食者。我非常相信并非常尊重捕食者。我所做的一切，我必须让它发生。”
Cunning, manipulative, I wrote in my reporter's note pad. This was ice and fire from the Bob Hare psychopath checklist. Al's statements may reveal a belief that the world is made up of predators and prey, that it would be foolish not to exploit weaknesses in others.
狡猾，操纵欲，我在记者笔记本上写道。这是鲍勃·黑尔精神变态清单中的“冷酷”与“火热”。艾尔的言论可能揭示了一种信念：世界是由捕食者和猎物组成的，不去利用他人的弱点是愚蠢的。
"Gold, too," I said. "There's a lot of gold here, too," I'd been prepared for the gold, having recently seen a portrait of him sitting on a gold chair, wearing a gold tie with a gold suit of armor by the door, and a gold crucifix on the mantle piece.
“金子，也有金子，”我说。“这里有很多金子，”我为黄金做好了准备，最近刚看到一幅他坐在金椅子上的肖像，戴着金领带，门口有金盔甲，壁炉架上有金十字架。
"Well," said Al. "Gold is shiny. Sharks." He pointed at a sculpture of four sharks encircling the planet. "I believe in predators," he said. "Their spirits will enable you to succeed. Over there, you've got falcons, alligators, alligators, more alligators, tigers."
“嗯，”艾尔说。“金子闪闪发光。鲨鱼。”他指着一个四条鲨鱼环绕地球的雕塑。“我相信捕食者，”他说。“他们的精神会使你成功。那边，有猎鹰，短吻鳄，短吻鳄，更多短吻鳄，老虎。”
"It's as if both Midas and also the Queen of Narnia were here," I said. "And the Queen of Narnia flew above a particularly fierce zoo, and turned everything there to stone and then transported everything here."
“这就像迈达斯（Midas）和纳尼亚（Narnia）的女王都在这儿，”我说。“纳尼亚女王飞过一个特别凶猛的动物园，把那里的一切都变成了石头，然后把一切都搬到了这里。”
"What?" said Al.
“什么？”艾尔说。
"Nothing," I said.
“没什么，”我说。
"No," he said. "What did you just say?" He shot me a steely, blue-eyed stare which I found quite debilitating.
“不，”他说。“你刚才说了什么？”他投给我一个冰冷的蓝眼睛凝视，我发现那非常令人虚弱。
"It was just a jumble of words," I said. "I was trying to make a funny comment, but it all became confused in my mouth."
“那只是一堆词，”我说。“我试图发表一个有趣的评论，但我在嘴里变得混乱了。”
"Oh," said Al. "Shall we get some iced tea?" he said.
“哦，”艾尔说。“我们要喝杯冰茶吗？”他说。
We gathered in the kitchen, Al, his wife, Judy, and Sean, the bodyguard. I cleared my throat. "You know, I said in my email that your amygdala might not shoot the requisite signals of fear to your central nervous system. And that's perhaps why you've been so successful, and so interested in the predatory spirit," I said.
我们在厨房聚集，艾尔，他的妻子朱迪（Judy），还有肖恩，那个保镖。我清了清嗓子。“你知道，我在邮件里说你的杏仁核可能没有向你的中枢神经系统发送必要的恐惧信号。而这也许就是你为什么如此成功，以及对捕食精神如此感兴趣的原因，”我说。
"Yes," he said. "It's a fascinating theory. It's like Star Trek . You're going where no man has gone before. Why are some people enormously successful, and others not at all? The kids I went to school with had a lot more privileges than me, but they're not successful. Why? What's different? Something's different. It's a question that's been on people's minds for generations. And that's why, when you mentioned this amygdala thing, I thought, hmm, that's very interesting. I'll talk to this fellow."
“是的，”他说。“这是一个迷人的理论。就像《星际迷航》（Star Trek）。你要去没有人去过的地方。为什么有些人非常成功，而另一些人却根本不成功？和我一起上学的孩子比我有更多的特权，但他们并不成功。为什么？有什么不同？有什么东西不同。这是一个几代人都在思考的问题。这就是为什么当你提到这个杏仁核的事情时，我想，嗯，这非常有趣。我会和这个人谈谈。”
"I have to tell you that some psychologists say that if this part of your brain doesn't work properly, it can actually make you--"
“我必须告诉你，一些心理学家说，如果你的大脑这部分工作不正常，它实际上可以让你——”
"Mmm?" he said.
“嗯？”他说。
"Dangerous," I mumbled inaudibly. I suddenly felt incredibly nervous.
“危险，”我模糊不清地嘟囔着。我突然感到非常紧张。
"Sorry?" he said. "I can't hear you."
“抱歉？”他说。“我听不见你说话。”
"Dangerous," I said. There was a short silence.
“危险，”我说。短暂的沉默。
"In what respect?" he said thinly.
“在什么方面？”他冷冷地说。
"It can make you, " I took a breath, "a psychopath."
“它可以让你，”我深吸了一口气，“成为一名精神变态者。”
Al, Judy, and Sean, the bodyguard, stared at me for a long time. I was in over my head. What did I think I was doing? I'm not a licensed medical professional or a scientist. Nor, if I'm being honest with myself, am I actually a detective. I blamed Bob Hare. He hadn't told me to do this, but I never would have had I not met him. His checklist gave me false confidence that I could make my way in this land of psychopaths. They looked at me, at once deeply angry, befuddled, and disappointed.
艾尔、朱迪和保镖肖恩盯着我看了很久。我自讨苦吃。我以为我在做什么？我不是执业医疗专业人士或科学家。诚实地说，我也不是侦探。我怪鲍勃·黑尔。他没让我这么做，但如果我没见过他，我永远不会这么做。他的清单给了我虚假的自信，以为我可以在这片精神变态者的土地上开辟道路。他们看着我，顿时深感愤怒、困惑和失望。
"I've got a list of personality traits written down here that define psychopathy," I said, pointing at my pocket.
“我这里有一张写着定义精神变态的人格特征清单，”我说，指着我的口袋。
"Who the hell are the people who make the list?" said Al. "What are their names? How about I never heard of them?"
“到底是谁在列这个清单？”艾尔说。“他们叫什么名字？我怎么从没听说过他们？”
At this, I realized I could turn the situation around, to make Bob Hare take the blame, in absentia, for the unpleasantness. "Bob Hare," I said. I pronounced his name quite clearly. "Bob Hare."
此时，我意识到我可以扭转局面，让鲍勃·黑尔因这些不愉快而承担责任（缺席的情况下）。“鲍勃·黑尔，”我说。我非常清楚地发出了他的名字。“鲍勃·黑尔。”
"I've never heard of him," said Al, a triumphant glint in his eye.
“我从没听说过他，”艾尔眼中闪过一丝胜利的光芒。
"Never heard of him," Judy agreed.
“没听说过，”朱迪同意道。
"He's a psychologist," I said. I exhaled, to indicate that I felt the same way he presumably did about psychologists.
“他是位心理学家，”我说。我呼出一口气，表示我感到和他认为的一样。
"So that list," said Al. He suddenly looked intrigued. "Go ahead," he said. "Let's do it."
“那么那份清单，”艾尔说。他突然显得很感兴趣。“来吧，”他说。“让我们做吧。”
"OK," I said. I pulled it out of my pocket. "Are you sure?"
“好的，”我说。我把它从口袋里掏出来。“你确定吗？”
"Yeah. Let's do it."
“是的。让我们做吧。”
"OK. Item one. Superficial charm."
“好的。第一项。肤浅的魅力。”
"I'm totally charming," he replied. "I am totally charming." He, Judy, and Sean laughed, easing the tension.
“我完全有魅力，”他回答。“我完全有魅力。”他和朱迪、肖恩笑了起来，缓解了紧张气氛。
"Grandiose sense of self-worth?" I asked. This was item two on the psychopath checklist. It would have been a hard one for him to deny, standing as he was below a giant oil painting of himself.
“狂妄的自我价值感？”我问。这是精神变态检查清单上的第二项。他站在自己巨大的油画下方，否认这一点对他来说很难。
"No question," said Al. "If you don't believe in yourself, nobody else will. You've got to believe in you."
“没问题，”艾尔说。“如果你不相信自己，别人也不会相信你。你必须相信你自己。”
"Is there another list of good things?" said Judy, quite sharply.
“有另一份关于好东西的清单吗？”朱迪尖锐地说。
"Well," I said. We all fell silent. "Need for stimulation, proneness to boredom?" I said.
“嗯，”我说。我们都沉默了。“寻求刺激，容易感到无聊？”我说。
"Yeah," said Al. "I'm very prone to boredom. I've got to go do something. Yeah. That's a fair statement."
“是的，”艾尔说。“我很容易感到无聊。我必须去做点什么。是的。这是一个公平的陈述。”
"Manipulative?" I said.
“操纵欲？”我说。
"I think you could describe that as leadership," he said. "Inspire. I think it's called leadership."
“我认为你可以将其描述为领导力，”他说。“激励。我认为这叫领导力。”
"Are you OK with this list?" I asked.
“你对这份清单满意吗？”我问。
"Yeah, sure. Why not?" he said.
“是的，当然。为什么不呢？”他说。
And so the morning continued, with Al redefining a great many psychopathic traits as leadership positives. Impulsivity was, he said, just another way of saying quick analysis. Some people spend a week weighing up the pros and cons. Me? I look at it for 10 minutes, and if the pros outweigh the cons, go. Shallow affect, an inability to feel a deep range of emotions, stops you from feeling what he called some nonsense emotions. And then there's a lack of remorse.
于是早晨继续进行，艾尔将许多精神变态特征重新定义为领导力的优点。他说，冲动只是快速分析的另一种说法。有些人花一周时间权衡利弊。我呢？我看10分钟，如果利大于弊，就行动。肤浅的情感，无法体验深层的情绪范围，阻止你感受到他所说的“一些无意义的情绪”。还有就是缺乏悔意。
"A lack of remorse," Al says, "just frees you up to move forward and achieve more great things. What's the point of drowning yourself in sorrow?"
“缺乏悔意，”艾尔说，“只是让你解脱，可以向前迈进，实现更多伟大的成就。沉浸在悲伤中有什么意义呢？”
It felt great. I congratulated myself on being a genius, on cracking him open. I found one. But when I got home to London from his house, and I listened back to the tape of my interview with him, I could hear how disappointed I sounded whenever he said things to me that didn't seem psychopathic. There'd been a moment, for instance, when I'd asked him about items 12 and 18, early behavior problems and juvenile delinquency.
感觉太棒了。我祝贺自己是个天才，成功攻破了他。我找到了一个。但当我从他家回到伦敦，听录音带采访时，我能听到每当他说出似乎不是精神变态的话时，我的声音听起来是多么失望。例如，当我问他关于第12项和第18项（早期行为问题和青少年犯罪）时，有那么一刻。
He'd told me, "No, I was a focused, serious kid. I was very determined. I was a good kid. In school I was always trying to achieve. I was always working hard. That saps your energy. You don't have enough time to trouble-make."
他告诉我：“不，我是一个专注、认真的孩子。我非常有决心。我是一个好孩子。在学校里，我总是努力取得成绩。我总是努力工作。那会耗尽你的精力。你没有足够的时间去惹麻烦。”
"You never got into trouble with the authorities?" I said.
“你从来没有遇到过法律问题？”我说。
"Nope," he said. "And remember, I got accepted into West Point. Listen, this psychopath thing is rubbish. You can't be successful unless you have certain," he pointed at his head, "controls. It won't happen. How do you get through school? How do you get through your first and second job, when you're formulating yourself?" It was a terribly persuasive point, and I'd felt disappointed when he said it.
“没有，”他说。“记住，我被西点军校录取了。听着，这个精神变态的事情是胡说八道。除非你有一定的，”他指着自己的头，“控制力，否则你不可能成功。那不会发生。你怎么通过学校？你怎么通过第一和第二份工作，当你塑造自己时？”这是一个非常有说服力的观点，当他说出来时，我感到失望。
Also, he denied being a liar. "If I think you're a schmuck," he said, "I'll tell you you're a schmuck." And I believed him. He denied having a parasitic lifestyle. "I'll go get my own meal," he said. And he did have a loyal wife for 41 years. There were no rumors of affairs. This would score him a zero in items 17 and 11, many short-term marital relationships, and promiscuous sexual behavior.
此外，他否认撒谎。“如果我觉得你是傻瓜，”他说，“我会告诉你你是傻瓜。”我相信他。他否认有寄生生活方式。“我会去给自己买饭，”他说。他确实有一位忠诚的妻子41年。没有外遇的传闻。这在第17项（许多短期婚姻关系）和第11项（滥交行为）上得0分。
We'd had lunch before I left his house. Al had seemed in surprisingly high spirits for a man who had just been questioned on which psychopathic traits most applied to him. As we ate, he told me funny stories about firing people. Each was essentially the same. Someone was lazy, and he fired them with an amusing quip. For instance, one lazy Sunbeam executive mentioned to him that he'd just bought himself a fabulous sports car. "You may have a fancy sports car," Al replied, "but I'll tell you what you don't have, a job."
离开他家之前我们吃过午饭。对于一个刚刚被询问哪些精神变态特征最适用于他的人来说，艾尔的精神看起来出奇的好。吃饭时，他告诉我关于解雇员工的有趣故事。每个故事基本上是一样的。有人很懒，他就用一句俏皮话解雇了他们。例如，一位懒惰的太阳能高管提到他刚给自己买了一辆漂亮的跑车。“你可能有一辆豪华跑车，”艾尔回答，“但我告诉你你没有的东西，一份工作。”
"You do feel good about yourself?" I asked.
“你确实对自己感觉良好吗？”我问。
"Oh, I do," he replied. "Oh, I do. "Looking back at my life is like going to a movie about a person who did all this stuff. My gosh, I did that. And through it all, I did it my way."
“哦，我是，”他回答。“哦，我是。回顾我的一生就像看一部关于做了所有这些事情的人的电影。天哪，我做了这些。通过这一切，我以我的方式做到了。”
Suddenly, I felt a little envious of him. I am the neurological opposite of a psychopath, in that I feel anxious almost all the time. It must be great to not constantly feel like you've got someone living inside of your face, shooting you with a mini taser. Sure, I'll confess to 16 out of the 40 possible points on the checklist. And you could reasonably give him another six points, which would put him in the 20's, which is high, but not the 29 or 30, which is the clinical line in the sand for psychopathy. And wouldn't it be nice to just be a little more like him, someone with no regrets about the past, no remorse, just kind of relaxed, and happy?
突然，我感到有点羡慕他。我在神经学上是精神变态者的对立面，因为我几乎一直感到焦虑。不总是觉得有人住在你的脸上，用小型泰瑟枪电你，那一定很棒。当然，我承认检查清单上40分里得16分。你也可以合理地给他再加6分，这会让他进入20多分，这很高，但不是临床上精神变态的界限29或30分。如果能稍微像他一点，对过去没有遗憾，没有悔意，只是放松和快乐，那该多好？
Jon Ronson, reading an excerpt from his new book, which is one of the inspirations for today's program, called The Psychopath Test.
乔恩·罗森，朗读他新书的节选，这是今天节目的灵感来源之一，书名叫《精神变态测试》。
[MUSIC - "IF I WERE KING OF THE FOREST" BY E.Y. HARBURG AND HAROLD ARLEN]
[音乐 - “如果我是森林之王”，艾·哈伯格（E.Y. Harburg）和哈罗德·阿伦（Harold Arlen）]
Act three, The Results are In.
第三幕，结果公布。
[ PSYCHO THEME MUSIC]
[精神变态主题音乐]
Who is the psycho? Thank you for that music cue. So if you heard at the beginning of today's program, you heard that I and my fellow producers here at This American Life decided to take the psychopath test ourselves for this week's program. And just to quickly repeat our caveats about that, we did this for entertainment and education purposes only, which meant that we took the short version of the test.
谁是精神病患者？谢谢那个音乐提示。如果你在今天节目开始时听到了，你听到我和《美国生活》的制作人决定为本周节目亲自参加精神变态测试。为了快速重复我们关于此事的警告，我们这样做只是为了娱乐和教育目的，这意味着我们参加的是测试的短版。
The doctor who administered the test didn't do the kinds of painstaking follow-ups that he normally does. For instance, he didn't look into court records to verify our stories. He took our word for all kinds of things, which he normally would not do if he was facing a real potential psychopath. That's because we assume that none of us was even close to scoring at psychopath levels on the test.
进行测试的医生没有做他通常做的那种艰苦的后续工作。例如，他没有查看法庭记录来验证我们的故事。他相信我们所说的一切，如果他面对一个真正的潜在精神变态者，他通常不会这样做。这是因为我们假设我们中没有人接近精神变态水平。
We figured that we would each score a couple points here, a couple points there. And then we wanted to see who would rack up the most points. Robyn and Jane, if you remember at the beginning of our show, were favorites because of trouble that they got into as teenagers. Teenage life is a lot of questions on the test. And then there was one more candidate for scoring points.
我们认为我们每个人会在这里得几分，那里得几分。然后我们想看看谁会获得最高分。罗宾和简，如果你记得节目开始的话，因为她们在青少年时期遇到的麻烦，是热门人选。青少年生活在测试中有很多问题。然后还有一个人是得分的候选人。
I thought, if you have the ego to say, like, I'm going to start my own radio show, that somehow you just are concentrated more on yourself in a way that would mean that you would lean that way.
我想，如果你有那种自大的勇气说“我要开始我自己的广播节目”，那不知何故，你只是在某种程度上更专注于自己，这意味着你倾向于那样。
I was just going to say you just more on the like-- like on the feelings stuff.
我刚才想说，你只是更多地关注——像是在感觉的东西上。
Yeah, the feeling stuff.
是的，感觉的东西。
Yeah, the feeling stuff. OK, this is going to come as news to anybody who only knows me over the radio, but not news to anybody who knows me in real life. As you might suspect about somebody who designed and created an entire radio show built around very personal conversations and moments where people really connect with each other, the only kind of person who would go to the trouble to invent a show like that will be somebody who in real life struggles with every one of those things, which I do. I can fake my way through social situations, of course, but people who really know me, like my coworkers do, know how detached, and anxious, and awkward I can be. Which is why they said, at the top of the program--
是的，感觉的东西。好吧，这对任何只通过广播了解我的人来说是个新闻，但对任何在现实生活中认识我的人来说就不是新闻了。正如你可能怀疑的那样，有人设计并创造了一个围绕个人对话和人们真正联系在一起的时刻建立的广播节目，只有会费心发明这样一个节目的人，在现实生活中才会与每一件事作斗争，我就是这样。当然，我可以在社交场合伪装，但真正了解我的人，像我的同事一样，知道我是多么疏离、焦虑和笨拙。这就是为什么他们说，在节目开始时——
Who do you guys think is going to have the highest score.
你们觉得谁的分数会最高。
You.
你。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yes.
没错。
I-- it's a toss up for me.
我——对我来说很难说。
This is Robyn.
这是罗宾。
As I was answering the questions, I kept thinking Jane's going to have such better answers than I am.
当我回答问题时，我一直在想简会有比我好得多的答案。
That's what I thought, too. Because Jane had more rough and tumble.
我也是这么想的。因为简有更多风风雨雨的经历。
Yeah, and like attendance in school.
是的，还有像在学校的考勤。
Yeah, I think my money's gone on to Jane, now.
是的，我想我现在的钱投给简。
This, by the way, is our show's senior producer, Julie Snyder.
顺便说一句，这是我们节目的高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。
So now, I know more about Jane's run-ins. I don't know so much about Robyn.
所以现在，我知道更多关于简的经历。我不那么了解罗宾。
Robyn, what do you got?
罗宾，你有什么？
So now I guess I got it between the two of you.
所以现在我猜我在你们两人之间选。
Problems with the law? Let's have a rundown.
法律问题？让我们做一个总结。
No, I had no problems with the law. I have none. I had, like, one cheating story, which who didn't?
不，我没有法律问题。我没有。我有过像作弊的故事，谁没有呢？
One--?
一个——？
Cheating story.
作弊故事。
Cheating, you mean, on a test?
作弊，你是说，在测试中？
In school. Like stealing a teacher's manual and lying about it. What, you guys didn't do that?
在学校。就像偷老师的手册并撒谎。什么，你们没做过吗？
OK, so let's go around and make our votes.
好的，让我们转一圈投票。
Oh, my God. Do we have to?
哦，天哪。我们必须这样做吗？
That's Jane, who didn't want to be number one.
那是简，她不想成为第一。
I'm going to go Robyn.
我选罗宾。
Julie?
朱莉？
Jane.
简。
I'm going to go with Jane.
我投简。
I think I'm going with Jane.
我想我会选简。
If I start crying while you guys are doing this, does that mean I'm not a psychopath?
如果当你们这样做时我开始哭，那意味着我不是精神变态吗？
Yes.
是的。
In the end, the final tally was Robyn with four votes, Jane with three, I had one. And Nancy, in a surprise move, I have to say, voted for herself.
最终，总票数是罗宾四票，简三票，我一票。而南希，以一个令人惊讶的举动，不得不说，投给了她自己。
I'm in this to win it. I just want to tell you all that. I don't know what game we're playing here, but I'm going to win.
我是来赢的。我只想告诉你们所有人。我不知道我们在玩什么游戏，但我会赢。
Then, our forensic psychologist, David Bernstein, joined us. He had actually heard us talking about how worried we were about our scores from the other room.
然后，我们的法医心理学家，大卫·伯恩斯坦，加入了我们。他实际上听到了我们在隔壁房间里讨论我们对分数的担心。
So you have there a stack of, actually, very official looking papers, and your notes, with all of our scores. Before we get to the actual scores, are there any patterns that you feel like you noticed in the group?
所以你那里有一叠看起来非常官方的纸，和你的笔记，上面有我们所有的分数。在我们得到实际分数之前，有没有你觉得在这个群体中注意到的任何模式？
Yeah, see, you guys are way too neurotic to really be psychopaths.
是的，看，你们太神经质了，不可能是精神变态。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Interestingly, half of you almost cried as I was asking some of the questions, by the way. That probably disqualified you from being a psychopath right there.
有趣的是，顺便说一句，我在问一些问题时，你们中有一半人差点哭了。那可能就让你失去了成为精神变态者的资格。
Dr. Bernstein explained to us that the way that the test is scored, for each of the possible psychopathic traits that you could have, you could get a zero, a one, or a two.
伯恩斯坦博士向我们解释说，测试得分的方式，对于你可能拥有的每一种潜在的精神变态特征，你可以得零分、一分或两分。
Two means you really have it. One means you have it, it's there, but maybe not to the same magnitude. And zero means it might have been something that occurred, but it's not nearly enough to reach the level of being scored. It doesn't reach that level. You guys want to know what your scores were?
两分意味着你确实有。一分意味着你有，它存在，但可能不是相同的程度。零分意味着它可能是发生过的事情，但远不足以达到评分水平。它没达到那个水平。你们想知道你们的分数吗？
Yeah, maybe we should start with the lowest scores first, and then go to the highest.
是的，也许我们应该先从最低分开始，然后再到最高分。
Well, this will be very easy, because you all scored a zero. Every one of you.
好吧，这很容易，因为你们都得了零分。你们每个人都是。
Wow, even Robyn?
哇，连罗宾也是？
Even Robyn. And this is because none of you really did anything maliciously. You never set out to predate, to hurt anyone. And even those of you who've done things, when I asked how do you feel about it? Most of you thought back on it with regret, and remorse. You're empathic, is what you all are, which is the opposite of psychopathy.
连罗宾也是。这是因为你们中没有人真正恶意地做过什么。你们从未打算去掠夺、伤害任何人。即使是你们中做过一些事情的人，当我问你感觉如何时？你们大多数人回顾时都带有后悔和悔意。你们是有同理心的，你们就是这样，这与精神变态正好相反。
This is the thing I think we wouldn't have understood as well if we hadn't actually gone through the trouble of taking the test ourselves, is just how categorically different psychopaths are from the rest of us. Dr. Bernstein joked that it's a lifelong commitment. Even the person who we thought would be the most likely to score a few points in the psychopath test, Robyn, at her most antisocial moment, stealing the teacher's manual in junior high school, apparently failed to do what any self-respecting, lacking-in-empathy psychopath would do. This next recording is from when Robyn took the test.
这是我认为如果我们没有亲自去参加测试，就不会理解得那么透彻的一件事，那就是精神变态者与我们其他人之间的分类差异是多么巨大。伯恩斯坦博士开玩笑说这是一项终身承诺。即使是被我们认为最有可能在精神变态测试中得几分的罗宾，在她最反社会的时刻，在初中偷老师手册，显然也没能做到任何自重的、缺乏同理心的精神变态者会做的事情。下一段录音来自罗宾参加测试时。
So here's a question. Now, you said you stole the manual.
所以有一个问题。现在，你说你偷了手册。
Yeah.
是的。
And you gave out the answers?
你把答案发给大家了？
Yeah.
是的。
Did you sell the answers?
你卖答案了吗？
No
没有。
Why'd you give them away?
你为什么要送给他们？
Just because we wanted everyone to do well.
只是因为我们想让每个人都做得很好。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
That is the mm-hm of I am bored. That's the mm-hm that you say when you're thinking, you people are not psychopaths.
那是“我很无聊”的嗯哼。那是当你心想“你们这些人不是精神变态”时说的嗯哼。
[MUSIC - "IF I ONLY HAD THE NERVE" BY E.Y. HARBURG AND HAROLD ARLEN]
[音乐 - “如果我只有勇气”，艾·哈伯格和哈罗德·阿伦]
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes, with the zero-scoring staff of Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Eric Mennel. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Jen Berman is filling in as our west coast producer.
好吧，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）制作，与艾力克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞门（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）组成的零分员工团队。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自埃里克·门内尔（Eric Mennel）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。简·伯曼（Jen Berman）正在担任我们的西海岸制作人。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who wants to move the show-- can you believe it?-- to Louisiana, for just one reason.
我们的节目由WBEZ管理监督，负责人托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia），他想把节目——你能相信吗？——搬到路易斯安那州，就为了一个原因。
Alligators, alligators, more alligators.
短吻鳄，短吻鳄，更多短吻鳄。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。